♪ ♪
>> IT IS A CLIMAX AND A TURNING
POINT.
THE INVESTIGATION HAS GONE ON
FOR SOME PERIOD OF TIME.
NOT TO INVOKE THE CLICHE, I JUST
WOULD HAVE TIME TO FISH OR CUT
BAIT CAN SEE EXACTLY WHAT THE
CONCLUSIONS ARE.
YOU DO NOT FOUL A DOCUMENT THAT
LOOKS LIKE THIS IF YOU ARE
INVESTIGATION IS IN THE FINAL
STAGES.
>> Bret: A LOT OF ANALYSIS OF
THE MICHAEL KOHN SENTENCING
DOCUMENT, FOLLOWED BY A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
AMONG THE PAGES, THEY PROVIDED
USEFUL INFORMATION CONCERNING --
IN THE DOCUMENT YOU WILL SEE
GIVEN NEEDED DEFENDANT'S
SUBSTANTIAL ASSISTANCE AND OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS, SENTENCE AT THE
LOW END OF THE GUIDELINE RANGE,
INCLUDING A SENTENCE THAT DOES
NOT INCLUDE A TERM OF
IMPERSONATION IS IMPORTANT.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL US?
WHERE ARE WE?
TOM ROGAN,
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER."
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, THE FEDERALIS
FEDERALIST.
ALL THE FOLKS WHO SAY, THIS IS
ALL COMING TO A HEAD.
IT COULD BE OVER SOON.
LOOKING AT THIS DOCUMENT, WE
CAN'T READ A LOT BECAUSE WE
DON'T SEE IT ALL.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THAT.
>> IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO KNOW IT
IS FRUSTRATING.
I THINK IT IS WORTH REMEMBERING
THAT THAT REASON WE KNOW ABOUT
THIS PHONE CALL THAT HE HAD WITH
THE RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR IS
BECAUSE A MEMBER OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION LEAKED THAT
INFORMATION TO THE MEDIA.
THAT WAS A CRIMINAL LEAK.
DAMAGE NATIONAL SECURITY AND NO
ONE HAS BEEN HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR IT.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION RATHER
VICIOUSLY SET THIS PRESSURE
NARRATIVE.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE LEAKS, THERE
WAS ALSO THE VERY QUICK LEAK OF
THE INFORMATION THAT JAMES COMEY
HAD BRIEFED DONALD TRUMP ON A
PARTICULARLY RIDICULOUS ASPECT
OF THE DISCREDITED DOSSIER THERE
WERE ALSO THE LEAKS ABOUT JEFF
SESSIONS COMPLETELY INNOCUOUS
MEETINGS WITH THE AMBASSADOR.
IF THAT REALLY SET THE
NARRATIVE.
IT UNDERMINED ADMINISTRATION.
IT IS HOW SOME REMEMBERS
ADMINISTRATIONS WERE HOUNDED AND
IT SET UP JUSTIFICATION FOR A
SPELL AND PROFESSIONAL COUNSEL.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER HOW
WE GOT HERE.
>> Bret: IT SEEMS ALSO THAT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL DESPITE HIS
PRODUCTIONS IS PUTTING OUT
THROUGH COURT FILINGS MORE OF
THE PICTURE.
WE ARE GOING TO GET ANOTHER ONE
EVENTUALLY.
PAUL MANAFORT.
>> THEY COULD HANG THIS IN THE
NATIONAL GALLERY, IT LOOKS LIKE
MODERN ART FROM THE 1960s.
THOSE BLACK LINES.
I'M NOT ACTUALLY SURE HOW MUCH
MORE WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT
ABOUT ANYTHING UNDERLYING THIS.
IN THE MENA PORT THING, HE HAS
SOMETHING GOING ON.
WHETHER IT MEANT A FORT ALLIED
OR EVEN TALKING ABOUT RETRYING
AMONG THE EIGHT OR TEN COUNTS
THIS LATEST REVELATION HAS THE
SAME STRUCTURE AS A LOT OF THEM
IN THE PAST.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL DOES
SOMETHING, DOES NOT ENTIRELY
CLEAR WHAT IT MEANS.
PEOPLE START DECLARING WHAT THEY
THINK IT MEANS BASED ON VERY
INSUFFICIENT INFORMATION AND
THEN IT ALL GOES QUIET AGAIN FOR
A WHILE.
I THINK THE BIG CHANGE NOW, THIS
INFORMATION IS ARRIVING AT A
TIME OF THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP THE HOUSE AND WHAT IS
REALLY GOING TO BE SIGNIFICANT,
IT IS HOW THEY PICK UP THE
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATIONS THAT
ARE DERIVED.
>> Bret: TOM.
>> WOULD KNOW WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW.
DETERMINES ME OF ANGLETON, THE
WILDERNESS OF MIRRORS.
ULTIMATELY I THINK ONE OF THE
INTERESTING THINGS HERE, WE DO
KNOW THAT MIKE FLYNN HAD THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE TURKISH
GOVERNMENT THAT WAS LISTED IN
THIS FILING.
KNOW THAT HE HAS BEEN VERY
INTERESTED IN TRYING TO GET HIS
FOLDS
WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY THE DETAILS OF
THAT, BUT THERE ARE AREAS HERE
SPEAKING TO FOREIGN POLICY WHICH
CAN BE BEYOND RUSSIA.
WE WILL SEE.
>> Bret: IT IS INTERESTING TO
SEE THE LOGAN ACT MENTIONED,
REACHING OUT TO FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS.
HE WAS AN INCOMING NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR.
IT IS LIKE HE WAS OUT OF
GOVERNMENT DEALING WITH FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS.
>> THAT IS WHY IT IS IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER HOW WE GOT HERE.
THAT WAS A LEAK.
THEY WERE LOOKING INTO THE LOGAN
ACT.
THEY ALSO LEAK THAT THEY WERE
WORRIED ABOUT THE BLACKMAIL,
SUBMIT IT DOESN'T APPEAR TO HER
KNOWLEDGE IN.
THERE IS A LOT THAT HAS NOT
BEEN --
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND THEIR ROLE
IS LETTING UP THIS NARRATIVE